the other day I talked briefly about the
murder of someone named Ryan Carson he's
the 32-year-old antifa activist who was
stabbed to death around 4:00 a.m. in
Brooklyn on Monday and I said that among
other things his killing shows the
importance of of knowing your
surroundings and taking proactive steps
to protect yourself and your family now
leftists can call that whatever they
want to call it stereotyping racial
profiling white supremacy whatever the
truth is it's common sense to get out of
a situation when you assess that you are
unsafe and if an agitated young male in
a hoodie on a street corner starts
kicking mopeds and ranting and raving in
front of you as Ryan Carson's killer did
then you don't stare at him you don't
tell him to chill or shove him several
times in the chest especially when he
says I'll kill you uh what you do is you
get yourself in your loved ones as far
away as you can if somebody calls you a
racist because of that then that's their
problem it's better to be alive and
quote unquote racist than dead and
tolerant now over the last 48 hours
though it's become very clear that the
murder of Ryan Carson is about much more
than what Ryan Carson did or failed to
do at 400 a.m. on Monday morning in
Brooklyn the response to Carson's
killing from all corners of the left
from Carson's friends to local
politicians to the media doesn't simply
tell us that leftists are hopelessly
naive and ignor ignorant of very real
threats to their lives it does tell us
that but it also tells us a lot more
because this is a this is a bigger story
than that it turns out now the response
to Ryan Carson's killing also makes it
clear that leftist simply don't care
about human life or Humanity in general
we know that because they're not even
going through the motions of
demonstrating some pretense of concern
for Carson much less uh the policies
that led directly to his death and what
this means is that is that leftism is
collectivism in every sense and at every
level it views its own adherence not as
people but as replaceable fungible cogs
in the revolution it uses its own
followers as essentially Canon fodder in
the culture War One death is uh is
irrelevant it's collateral
damage now we could debate when this
began or whether it's always been the
case with leftism but it it's impossible
to dispute that the left is openly
admitting this now consider the fact
that within hours of Ryan Carson's death
his left-wing friends set up a GoFundMe
and that part is not unique you know
this happens a lot somebody dies and
next thing you know there's a GoFundMe
but the thing is that they didn't create
this GoFundMe to cover funeral CA or to
help Carson's family instead Carson's
friends set up a GoFundMe for themselves
so that so that so that they could skip
work uh in order to mourn that's not an
exaggeration it's precisely what they
wrote here's the pitch on their GoFundMe
page quote we are collective of Ryan's
close friends reeling from a brutal loss
we're asking for your help on behalf of
his partner in easing the burden and
stress of this horrifying situation so
that we can have space and time to
grieve and remember Ryan immediate needs
are to offset the costs of workingclass
people taking time off of work to
properly mourn so they want to take a
vacation they want vacation days uh and
uh and they want to be paid they want a
paid vacation and they need to crowdfund
for that crowdfunding some bement leave
even though they're not even related to
the guy like forget the family forget
the funeral apparently just pay them to
sit around and and
mourn I mean think about this their
friend died this all happened this start
this Monday early Monday morning as when
when he was killed so and the gami was
up very quickly so their friend died I
mean brutally horrifically stabbed to
death in the
heart bleeding to death on a sidewalk
right and the first thing they think to
do is start a GoFundMe to raise funds
for
themselves which means that someone in
the friend Circle had to suggest this
almost immediately after he died did you
hear Ryan was killed that's all it's
awful you know we should start a
GoFundMe oh for funeral cost no no no
for us so we could take some time off
work and then everyone else apparently
agreed to
it it's it's incredible but Ryan's
comrades didn't start uh stop there
rather for good measure they also told
media Outlets that if he were alive Ryan
would feel bad for his killer as the
Daily Mail reported quote Brooklyn
activist Ryan thoris Carson would feel
sorry for the violent teenager who
stabbed to death and think of him as a
victim of a broken system say friends
unfortunately Ryan Carson could not be
reached for comment on this and although
if we're being completely honest his
friends are probably right on social
media before his death Carson celebrated
violence directed at police officers he
called the torching of a Minneapolis
Police Station quote really good he
cheered when Rush limbal died saying
quote hell yeah he also threatened an
elected official saying that he wanted
to quote shove this little effing nerd
in the locker where he belongs at the
same time Carson pretended to be a comp
passionate person when he was talking
about violent Thugs and drug addicts who
he wanted to have constant state-funded
access to
narcotics so the criminals who terrorize
entire cities are the good guys
according to Ryan Carson but the talk
radio hosts and politicians who disagree
with him on the other hand well they
deserve to die now as depraved an
ideology as that is this is what
resonates on the left now Carson's
friends value that ideology more than
the memory of their dead
friend they want to promote the very
same policies defunding the police
legalizing injection sites uh putting
the mentally ill homeless back on the
streets they want to they want to lean
into those policies that got Carson
killed in the first place that's because
they don't care about him they care
about the
revolution now you might have heard
claims on social media that Carson's
girlfriend who was with him when he was
killed Claudia there have been reports
on social media that she was not
Cooperative with police in the hours
after her boyfriend's death and we can't
confirm that so I don't know if that's
true or not uh certainly if it's true it
would be in keeping with Claudia's
social media posts where she says that
all cops are bastards but here's what we
do know according to the New York daily
news Claudia somehow mispick quote
unquote mispick her boyfriend's killer
in a lineup and she's the only
eyewitness to the crime she saw it
happen right in front of her from just a
few feet away but she reportedly
misidentified the person who did it now
without seeing all the people on the
lineup it's hard to make anything out of
that eyewitnesses are also iously
unreliable but it is another interesting
detail to note all the same politicians
in New York don't appear to be
interested in getting to the bottom of
any of this um or making sure that these
sort of things don't happen again like
Carson's friends they are motivated
solely by ideology so take a look at
so-called tributes to Ryan Carson from
New York state senator Julia Salazar or
public Advocate jumaine Williams or
council member Sandy nurse or state
senator Jabari brisport or state
representative em Emily
gager and all of these tributes that
have been pouring in none of them talk
exactly about how Carson died uh or
anything like that instead they all
mindlessly tell people to continue
practicing his brand of leftwing
activism Salazar for example eulogized
Carson by talking about the importance
of Humane drug policy Williams went on
about the need for environmental
justice they're skipping over any form
of self-reflection about why Ryan Carson
is dead in favor of repeating their
talking
points it's like callus and Craven
doesn't even begin to describe
this of course wherever there's callus
and Craven Behavior there's also the
corporate media and they've also been
working overtime to obscure as many
facts as possible about this antifa foot
soldiers unfortunate demise in the hours
after Carson's murder several outlets
including the New York daily news and
New York Post refused to provide any
kind of description for the suspect even
though we could see it on security
camera footage so we all knew some of
the basic basic details of his descri of
his physical description the New York
daily news for example called the Killer
and quote unhinged stranger the article
later describes the murder as a
belligerent stranger but there's no
mention of any kind of description even
though the article cites police sources
who have clearly seen the surveillance
footage showing the
murder so this is deliberate either the
police or the media or Carson's
girlfriend decided to hide some of the
information there's no getting around
that and as as as incredible as that is
it gets worse somehow in a development
that's unprecedented in New York's
storied history of per walks this cover
up continued even after police arrested
Carson's alleged killer yesterday when
police arrested uh the suspect who
allegedly stabbed Carson to death on the
street CBS News made the editorial
decision to blur the alleged Killer's
face they deliberately hid his identity
watch watch this this is footage of of
the man police say they were looking for
he has not yet been identified but we
are blurring his face at the moment
while charges are pending uh we watched
again as all of this went down more than
a dozen officers were around when it
happened before entering a home here on
Lafayette
Avenue I mean it it's amazing like like
to be perfectly clear the suspect that
police arrested is an 18-year-old adult
by the name of Brian Dowling there is no
conceivable reason to blur his face in
this context the excuse from CBS which
appears to be well this adult murder
suspect hasn't been formally charged yet
so therefore you don't get to see his
face this has never been used by any
major media Outlet in the history of
this country as far as we can tell it's
never been used by
CBS the thousands of times they have put
footage of people getting arrested on TV
and they have never blurred the
face they certainly didn't do that with
Daniel peny
Daniel Penney didn't kill anyone in Cold
Blood he's not a murderer he saved
people on a subway car from getting
violently
attacked which which by the way you
remember that in that case Jordan Neely
was going crazy on a subway Daniel Penny
intervened and we're told that Jordan
Neely uh he was not a threat to anyone
he wasn't he wasn't uh you know he
wasn't waving a gunar
around well you see in the case of Ryan
Carson how quickly it goes from
belligerent guy screaming to stabbing
someone to death okay in the span of
seconds uh uh Brian Dowling went from
screaming on a street corner to stabbing
a man to death that's how quickly that
that happens people always say happy dog
happy life well I always say I say it
all the time it's the Mantra I live by
and if that's really the case you need
to be giving your dog rough greens
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough greens is dedicated to
improving the health of every dog in
America before I started feeding my dog
rough greens I had no idea that dog food
is dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green well
let rough greens bring your dog's food
back to life rough greens is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy a new dog
for you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident Ru greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it a free jump start
trial bag can be at your door in just a
few business days go to Ru greens.com
mat or call 844 ru700 that's rfffg
greens.com or call 844 ru700 today these
days I'm constantly traveling being on
the road as much as I am I don't sleep
well at night I know it's because the
hotel sheets are not as comfortable as
my cozy Earth sheets at home czy Earth
sheets are the softest most luxurious
streets i' sheets I've ever owned my
wife and I have their white bamboo
sheets on our bed those bamboo sheets
are temperature regulating helping us
sleep great every night if you're a hot
sleeper and your spouse is a cold
sleeper you're going to need these
sheets cozy Earth offers an array of
sizes and 11 colors to match your Unique
Style and preferences their sheets are
made to withstand the test of time my
Cozier sheets get softer and softer with
every wash don't just take my word for
it they have over 5,000 happy customer
reviews on their site what are you
waiting for cozy Earth offers a 100
night guarantee so there's no harm in
trying and invest today and a good night
sleep right now you'll save 40% off your
next purchase with promo code walsh4
cozy earth.com that's promo code walsh4
cozy earth.com
did Daniel peny save people on the
subway from the same fate it's quite
possible and yet even before Daniel
Penny was outrageously charged with any
crime news outlets had no problem
putting his face everywhere
before he was before he was
arrested what explains the different
treatment well of course Daniel penny is
whites and Brian dling is
black that shouldn't matter but when
corporate media makes everything about
race it's hard not to notice and more to
the point Daniel Penny was a law-abiding
citizen he served his country and the
Marines then he exercised his right of
self-defense and his right to defend
others around him so naturally they want
to shame it shame him at every
opportunity Brian dling on the other
hand he did exactly what left his wanted
him to do if what authorities are saying
is true he contributed nothing to
society instead he committed a bunch of
crimes behaved like a lunatic and
terrorized everybody around him in fact
shortly before uh he murdered the uh
antifa activist in Brooklyn ding was was
allegedly uh involved in other uh kinds
of incidents let's watch this what we've
learned about 18-year-old Brian dling is
that there appears to have been a
summons from last year for disorderly
conduct and that just a couple months
ago after dling was in an argument with
his girlfriend at her apartment he was
breaking things and it actually led to
his aunt calling 911 and describing him
as emotionally disturbed there's a lot
of uh thoughts that maybe there's a
mental health aspect to it but certainly
it is a brutal murder that happened with
this man stabbed to death in front of
his own
girlfriend so instead of throwing Brian
dling in an asylum where he apparently
belonged leftist policies ensured that
he wouldn't spend a day in any kind of
institution the fact he he may have
killed a leftist is unfortunate in their
eyes but don't really care a little bit
of a friendly fire in their view which
shouldn't distract from their
agenda now we've been seeing this a lot
lately the other day I mentioned the
brutal murder of a 26-year-old white
left-wing Tech CEO in her luxury
apartment building in Baltimore uh the
CEO named pava leer was an avowed
leftist she had BLM propaganda all over
her social media feeds she seemed to
really Harbor an irrational hatred
towards white men how did she die well
she led a black guy she didn't know into
her apartment building and then she she
got into an elevator with him the
surveillance footage shows all of this
Le's mangled dead body was found on the
rooftop of her apartment a few days
later now if you were covering this
story and pretty much every news station
in the Baltimore area has covered it
then you think you'd at least want to
inform viewers of exactly how Le was
murdered but that's not what's happened
so here's one example of a local news
coverage of Le's death this is from Fox
St Louis and I want you to notice what
is not mentioned here
have new developments surrounding the
investigation into the woman who was
killed inside an apartment complex near
Mount Vernon well City police are now
saying they found the body of ecomap CEO
pava leier leir inside the complex that
was once the historic Congress Hotel
investigators say there were signs of
blunt force trauma detectives were
originally called to the building after
someone reported the 26-year-old missing
police are asking anyone with
information that could help solve this
case to contact them so a lot of reports
are like this they say that she was
killed in her apartment building but
they don't tell you how the killer got
inside and that's a curious Omission
when you think about it because if you
really cared about pava leer or even if
you just cared about accuracy in
journalism you'd think that uh maybe
that would be one of the first things
you mentioned pava leer let this killer
into her building she died because she
was too welcoming she was too trusting
she was too tolerant too
naive she died because she didn't make
stereotypical
assumptions why not tell that story to
the public now the Omission is
particularly notable given recent
history it wasn't all that long ago that
the media told us that unless we allow
every random black guy into our
apartment buildings then we're racist
and we should lose our job so here's a
story that you almost certainly don't
remember it's from the dark ages of
2018 and um that year a white woman
named Hillary Thornton decided to block
a black man from entering her apartment
building Hillary had cracked the door to
let her dog out that an unknown black
guy tried to enter the building and
Hillary said that she that she wouldn't
allow him inside what happened next
while the entire national news media
branded Hillary thoron as a racist and
she was fired from her job watch we are
hearing the other side of a story that's
making National headlines a white woman
inside a downtown Loft building not
letting a black man inside Friday night
has hit social media and gone viral and
the woman in the video says he didn't
have a key fob to get in and forced his
way inside she reached out to me to tell
her side of the story after being called
a racist and receiving death threats
it's an exclusive interview you will see
only on Fox 2 tonight she blocking me
into my building okay and it's my
building as well so I need you to get
out my way this is the viral video of
Hillary thoron trying to stop Darion
tolls from entering the Elder shirt
Lofts just off Washington in the city
thoron wanted people to know her side of
what happened so when I noticed an
individual that I did not know my only
intent was to follow the direction that
I've been given by our condo association
board members repeatedly and that is to
never allow access to any individual
that you do not know thoron showed us
several emails from the association
stating what residents should do when
dealing with a situation like this
Hillary says Doran said he was trying to
get into the building as she had the
door cracked as dog went to the bathroom
and I simply asked if he lived there
mhm because the direction from the condo
association is so
repeated that if you don't know the
person you do not let them in Thor ad
she told him she couldn't let him in
then asked if he had a key fob that's
the only indicator that any Resident has
that they live in that
building he would not answer
me so Hillary Thornton's life was
destroyed because she did the right
thing she did what her Condo Association
told her to do she also did what common
sense tells you to do you got someone
who you don't recognize in the building
doesn't have a keyop won't even tell you
that they live there don't let them in I
wouldn't pav laer on the other hand did
what the left at corporate media
demanded and now she's dead because of
it and none of the activists who gave
her that horrible advice none of the
media Outlets that relentlessly attacked
Hillary thoron are acknowledging any of
that like Ryan Carson's friends they
don't care they're worried instead about
the cultural revolution they don't care
about the innocent people who die as a
result you might have noticed that there
have been several other prominent
examples recently of leftist uh
activists dying horrible deaths because
of left-wing policies this is becoming
more and more common and with every new
tragic example the responses from the
left is always the same it's detached
it's
self-absorbed completely focused on
politics all of them corporate media
politicians the foot soldiers in
Brooklyn they all want their ideology to
win that's all they care about people do
not matter to them human life doesn't
matter to them the higher the body count
the more forcefully they'll clamor for
social
justice every fatality is more evidence
that they're right somehow what they'll
never admit is that Ryan Carson and pava
leer and many more victims like them
have already experienced the inevitable
consequences of this suicidal insane
ideology and precisely for that reason
no one will ever hear from them
again if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed